personally I'm hoping multi-platform is
the way of the future so we can all
enjoy the best of what video games have
to offer no matter which video game lots
we decide to sink our money into but for
now here's the gains from e3 this year
that are coming exclusively to your
console of choice diehard playstation 4
devotees have a pretty sweet selection
of exclusives to look forward to which
take you from androids all the way to
zombies yep zombies are still big this
year apparently one of the most exciting
offerings coming to ps4 in my opinion is
Quantic Dream's detroit become human the
same team who brought you heavy rain and
beyond two souls are working on this new
narrative driven game well play a choice
and plot twists menu once again be able
to [ __ ] everything up by choosing the
wrong dialogue options become human is
set in a futuristic society where
androids live and work alongside humans
if some robots still isn't enough robots
for you horizon zero dawn is still on
the horizon you'll mainly be using
primitive but kind of high-tech weapons
to take out some very not so primitive
metal foes the action RPG looks like it
will pack a punch when it comes out next
februari and a really visually stunning
one at that if you feel like beating up
gods again god of war is coming back
with a vengeance and this time you'll be
using your powers of angry to take on
the North Pantheon while juggling the
trials and tribulations of fatherhood
and feels if zombies are more your speed
Ben Studios is releasing days gone a new
IP where you play a biker bounty hunter
it takes place two years after a
worldwide pandemic turned a whole lot of
people in to freakers these are the ones
you'll be pointing your gun at unless
they jump off your appendages last but
not least other ps4 titles vying for
your attention this year at e3 included
a new spiderman game from sunset
overdrive dead insomniac games and of
course today okajima's moody and spooky
death stranding they drink his BFF
Norman Reedus those of you prefer your
consoles to be of the Xbox variety just
listen to a whole bunch of games that
you can't actually play so here's what's
in store for you I should mention that
while this is a console exclusive
specific video a bunch of these gay
can also be played on pc for those
looking for something a little different
and a lot twisted there's we happy few a
mildly terrifying roguelike survival
game where the inhabitants are all high
up some medication called joy also some
of them look like freaky clowns not
great for those of you with agoraphobia
that's the afraid of clowns one if
you're into games with numbers on the
end Microsoft are all set to deliver
halo wars 2 as well as Gears of War for
which is two out before the end of the
year here's our floor is slated to be a
whole lot darker than previous entries
and will feature weather effects couch
carp and a brand new threat to
humanity's survival because of course
there is you're also playing the son of
Marcus Fenix so check this one out see
how far the apple falls from the tree
fall to horizon 3 is back and taking
place in various places around Australia
objectively the best location they could
have picked but if you'd prefer to claw
your way as far from realism as possible
you've got scalebound this action title
coming next year gives you a dragon best
friend to fight alongside and all manner
of enemy beasties to sikkim on microsoft
also kicked in a reminder that the
lovely looking Rico is on its way so not
to worry Xbox fans you can get your
robot fix on Xbox one as well finally
there's the criminally fancy of thieves
criminal because it's about pirates who
mercy criminals if you've ever wondered
how well you and a pack of friends would
fare on the high seas you'll soon be
able to find out expect shouting at one
another to patch hull breaches while you
play your cannon to approaching ships
and it suddenly dawns on your crew that
no one is manning the ship's wheel a las
anecdote was based on a true story
unsurprisingly we suck and Nintendo has
Zelda that's the end of our video thanks
for watching I'm kidding I have Bertha
3d asunder Wii U let's talk in 10 doh
Nintendo do indeed have zelda boy do
they have zelda the legend of zelda
breath of the wild is the biggest zelda
game that's ever been made the game
features a gorgeous 3d home world of
voiced characters and a ton of new tools
mechanics like cooking weapon
degradation and physics systems that all
interact with each other in a crazy
amount of
it's extremely exciting for those of us
who've grown up with the franchise but
it's not the only thing intend to have
on their plate they had one more thing
they want to talk about this year
Pokemon Sun and Moon Nintendo showed off
some new gameplay and the brand new
battle mode like a leaf in Nintendo
these two games seem big enough to carry
them for the moment obviously the
publisher have a bunch of other games in
the works as well as a new console we
know almost nothing about but these were
the highlights for the publishers III
present let me know what exclusives
you've got your eye on and bell yet let
me know if you're a fan of exclusives or
if you'd prefer to see games go
multi-platform leave me your thoughts in
that box